on his express
selection
google cloud storage in hell
ivan south by force start i want a
setting of the organizer sochi great and
where we can hear our experience and i
want a soft antifa brought speaker order
hex client about peter architect and
today oats i k  balsan details about
here architect hold a midi file to
work with google cloud storage back and
be for start to have a pup
they give you uses and google cloud amazon
microsoft ram and cheese work corner also
find good athens to for me to be defined as
[ __ ] for all other sympathize ok
extending jupiter without google cloud
storage file system back and can you
hear me well i speak like this is ok
about arrays and its arcade source
dsd it's santis my hair manager on
robotics both zen and switch to the
machine learning  in the south and when
the company itself is pretty
start up it's round vente people in madrid
secure a repository swallow for world
surrounds me once a repository
svante millions surprised pe  rson with hop beat
tanks dance with kill here go crazy
machines learning stop stop on top of this
right now we be the implementation engl
video building a bible fish & project
credit extract abstract syntax 3 from
the cold and we have many other of
projects for three  konchak he aura guide hop
repository
intact and fig she panel here presentation
he her device and finish click on the
link and tagged hop repository deep and
ok here because of plans and speech brought
and explain the baltimore sun way we
decided to mike with glasses will give  u know
fork splines bolts google cloud in
dense here i give with howie account used when
we explain
about g peter site will improve be modified
here account be bride in the work with
google cloud zoom beko ce and cannot
explain each line of code but we  have a
ride on a wing
line concept half example  n the continent ok
shin-mo tevosyan's motives from release simple
repair of possibility skinny
laptop easily solve don't want to copy
laptop from tayan server itself other
server to hear it is sambody with you what
you and for deployment this cop
frag filled with learning cluster  and it
automatically cheese laptop owls either from
google cloud storage kind of min but them and
persis there on the box and in the sampling bed head
in communication and visa cluster from the servers it
fails and even and work still i don't lose
and and the son's laptop crashed  you can use
this solution is reference to make your
own
extension for amazon simple storage
solution may be for microsoft mind back
once on so long and westeast
your life easier to mike community life
easier and stabbed flowing was spain for
evri badi
there self fic  background
ok about google cloud and odorous bunch of
services over focus only on google cloud
storage bots consist of money defran
service volume
from maneuver ok ivan
storage in database is bing is big
bunch  of services and you just focus
only
he his on charged google claus exactly
ok to start visas
from their place of the dust and today the
model of google cloud storage
zara fog class is bored and block
package from
self comments basic container due to container
ouya data  for you won space and
on google cloud and blog with a
concepts roasting so it represents a
and does not give and does not diathesis you want a stare
like i'm watch next
as any other file he here file
would say sports & blogs
basis blogs due  no cake im baked im
container
another notis fragrant wenge open
google cloud storage i can sing it is it
has her or folders
bate diver baked a stores anneal son
flat namespace it min 40 castles even if
i and north what folders and look and
plots blogs it  means for example i
can create blog related to folder and
save slash antenna if you try to open it
in your
with cake in this interface and trend
web interface and some other google and
this allows you to you swear to her off
as can  crown lackey for first film time
to explain
from sqlite a client and price entry point
google cloud storage using dice client
century on ces auer data attached to the sun
project and we can create baked
completely recipe information francis
bacon and i can see which are available
for this  specific client next fink and
dogs top container offset container all
blacks inside it has many different
methods that in your work we need only
small only seen a lot of
photo
bodzin
and a pocket of slabs the whole block off the block and how the
smell of cinnamon here is a block of gasoline and fruit with
data and only desmond behind google cloud
storage
any modi fight next i can copy blogs
he baked to you nazar baked and murder
and explain the beat maker and candida here
bucket and candida blogs
i can receive
absinthe ren & blogs
inside of per baguette and is experience per
object it represents a ne olar date in
google c  loud storage access content type
for just the site so we can download it
as string
we can check if it existential programs on
history and here factory constructor
special effects style we can check if a
here was a prize like existential
he is from winter to the tips of the toilet to
encourage it  last time and we can modify
this blog is it all by four zero
many different methods bad for a archey the
lights go out five
ok g peter site
hanks explain the overall
fracture of g peter ma case will explain
what about free classic  but blame you
because of the accepted
implement a work to work with google
dick and so first class at a venit jus
from content manager so it's a klasa but
dvorkovich file system so it can deftly
phrases for
you can in heart from this class in zen
we can work with norm file system i can
work with google cloud file system i can work with google cloud file
system and he you from and
it has a glass of long since ask
southwark visa file system like separate
file check if i d  directory file existential
recipe get a and c
archive fashionable for fashion reviews
about fashion and explain capu slightly to
send to check if this file is hidden
it can be used in linux cases
can say for example z i
wanted to have
hidden files  for laptop stand
itself file suites intermediate reasons for
laptop beko ce for laptop excel file
update war click baton safe out of the
sense of the storm and check point and
its and nazarov helper class this accepted
document lied more functions a credit
check point for file nicknames  by info
laptop Feb 3 check point for file
ndfl wars laptop ok here from fashion
let me explain to me get claire for model
from female not giving concept z allows you to
extract from a file syste  m soldier
mindset and up to 7 meters without hiv file
system works if i were present food is an
elastic band with glasses giving an interface you can
easily create back once for different
file systems for your is better than
distant here fashion salavat we have here
it dictionary
order lied fields  mandate refills why
buse him because of the name of an
file folder that will be shown in
your peter programs guilty open browser yu
si list of file soloists folders and behind
it entries from forms here mod zen smell
because of paw in file system for  3 usb type a
for only free types in jupiter from file it's
laptop n it's directory
zen it's info swamp when it was
credit info bold vintage modified
15 views
but still sam content of finishing by
file laptop folder and to by water
cord fields for man and  mind up i can
find it is an application of top bad to
it's not rely true
big o sa aura files can be included in
several formats and i have to specify
z specific formats you study course this
file exte  nsion swamps file modem their autospec strikes
for type is file
went out zen my type a and c media type
helped true internet so it's either
explain your
applications stream of applications that
seeks upstrak time abstract type
that i can you for any files and if i
don't know how to encounter about his the
righteous decoder logris zone format
with sizer
so soon basic for an den female endo
content that i want to put the studies
files
laptop sau type is laptop my type is
applications
x ah-ah-ah png  jason from and to laptop
ses cake jason format and and content
is content laptop ok in the last
you this directory mod whole them this
directory is start m jason tu and
content is important to content is a
list of a [ __ ] and free modules of
content  of this folder sell it means it
from way in a folder in her bunch of
files and
for i don't
need to star  ecieve information and can
request from google cloud storage
backend ok yo mike female without giving a
screw we are looking for we have right now that
we have to do we have to implement the
class is its content manager and to
check point from the wind and methods
there mandatory  to implement and devious
free different classes from google cloud
storage back and paint bucket
and blog and fifteen method south of these
five pretty good
litter mayor the lot of methods to
yes
ok workflow
this this part of presentation will
explain
your going on when you press  battle in
browser
here with going in you back and how from
jupiter works scales google cloud file
system to make it will give and bad we'll
start from
initialization regards import import how
i have to can shapes in rising sun we can
view with jupiter google cloud  dick and
cut their holes have to follow
google cloud  ys own a 2 tr.
google cloud platform web interface
faint baton cardin chill in the download
jason file z contents ki informational
you can connect to server
nextep eat and not whole jupiter co
from s default pav in configuration of
laptop from cake
fisting but u have to do we have to
minchin z and change a file system back and
soul it's content manager class but
instead of default you ass work swiss
norm file system you going to you with
him ass from jupiter head google watchman
cloud manager next finca if you can
specify edition information frag sample
if i don't want is default project from
google class can specify project
eyes when you can specify allocation of
whiskey file for three downloaded from web
interface and freedom for and end
default for google cloud
if i don't want to start from for  the root of the
directory i can write off the baguette and the
block itself is the start of
several more
implementation details about past the elegant
maximum bramble abs chrome package and its to
asis part in and when you descried was
optimizations details optima
copywriters of jupiter and google cloud
storage backend ok this start here
google cloud storage web interface and made
fun
but he was either for power company can sit
you don't qstring ass blames lounge & g
petersov
image slim we got all bug behind or
phase project  and uses folders for a
word cosplay and forever what to
poke men
's going on when you open jupiter
laptop
so and its frag plows from
van folder you another folder
at first i have to recieve information on the
swamp baked bad if i have the  back of a
big as when you in a
rat folder  bucket site to list a
blob sabbath franklin site to list buckets
for nbk [ __ ] you often list blogs and we
cried vogue
aur directories when using here
moodle.org peter laptop and cloth sat down for
content it can show of  files that are
available and it can be a loser and
briefing inbrowser next fink and here is
how we create files and folders
navi have to work with client it's
rare them baked zen we have to work
with bag it when we have to find a
volleyball name by indirect create new
file folder
and pity scout on tight and it has an
prefix this feint and you love the
author behind  name is found and concret content
driven antenna
compressive hook grand prix say [ __ ] it so
out of scales of maya presentation but
in reality
it can be you submit case itself with zone
wi-fi free general son scales laptop when
we say file and when we  say a folder to
help or function that we have so even if
we found z
disney is available still we have to
check the file when
we can by default content
mc laptop spelling by if you modify
your laptop ivan pass  ive a laptop and the right
is the law, then here the laptop of the earth them and
stuck in a hurry helper function from the
peter the check and the law is plugged there
and on the court format but on fimka is broken
in the content for me another 37 blog and
update sbl of additional step
but them  of the credit check point for
netbooks because of not available
even though we will get existential soen cases
file it's diamond 7 often bit simple or by
class we don't need to mike points for
content videos stronghold this block for whole
bad i have to  be careful because when
you in a rut folder with mint then
started a quiz client directly but twice
baked baht mysql and i cannot create blog
folder you can only have a
directory is not files
sale and save directory simple
so if we
can create new bag it if we in baku jazz
creed mti block z with self list and
content type and empty content and share
file icon sets a  bit complexity that  i
have to remember about the total for 300
communities and fio
rut level can i have to work squeal line
than they have to remove baked sights
if you in baked i have the rim of blogs
next finca if its founder and cumin stuffing
tore to summer recursive  content of this
folder as we have the rim of files on
countrymen here function recursive for
each folder in site on delivery
fink you by
david and  butt and
chinche dogs from here block lettuce minutes 8
you are rich battle on your name it go to
another baked indis case from first i have
you copy blog from one bathed in other
baked and zen fit directory their author
name of blocks recursively
and if it's  just one files their mouths him he
flea vanga openfile just a file system
cherry torn
correct fashion in here file sau
allergy peter can handle it correctly
make love as and taste and lancet write a
work at
spring and 1 baht he wants himself times we
need  to die bucks
here could help help or function which
makes your life easier
wrap power functions
links to decorate our end and when ages
past from then we print info bal des
funcion about option shutter post here
function and inventory print all so
simple as a result  of this function is
how it help to solo tu daebak here was
going wrong of example i can check for
info this content in fashion and cutting
temples and click ok
about optimizing oyho behind the genes of the
programs by losing the pass in it
interview in google and when you ask  how
to optima due to algorithm for fest
one due to blink on your mind stork eat
and and union hashtag so we decided to use
some say that is my mother and patterns
and you will see all objects from for baguette
this mindset we do not send money request
a back and save often
center quest update saving and it min z
edwarg faster baht for problem riza and
charter discount fully
site min z i can switch it he in
configuration can switch it off in
configuration
per point but i have to keep in mind if
i from cash-in samba de les can modify
files in this file system in google
store and send your cash may be my big
an incorrect
it's a moment of time to land and you have
a lot  of problems so i've seen her since
i work in pure love
keep in mind is it may be i have to
switch off
orc customer bit slow bath and i will
not have any kind of errors and next
fink
optimization in cases baked beyond carved
limitation  number of blocks in
these kinds of our company makes
change but viking star
there million blocks in one baked from min
40 chained want a list blogs
more to reach out in my lenses blogs and
it's quite a lot of time for example if
i don  't want to avoid the long and we by
the list and files in your browser you
can specify the maximum typing element i
will go to athens to it was a lot of
details for points here presentation
and tether from flp phrases on air de site
in which  makes a few clicks is not
understand how it works
in  ternally sent them and i have my
thoughts i saloni clarins
[applause]
request and you can see
crusts and towers are good do so i'm so
sick and
it takes chance in cases concurency is
bad it gives handel 10 chance for pandas from
fragments
one  person here and here laptop for 7
times and it handles this is another server
may feel of example you don't want to
copy l laptop table new cruiser wars
and just be deployed p.def out so it's for
show off height is not at  work in
competitor your new channel for carved and
dots and in the body itself works your
zara limitations are overgrown
and i have to keep the limitations in
mind
[applause]